i felt like it was very difficult for
people to take me seriously i felt like
a joke you know selena gomez is getting
real about life after disney
[Music]
yeah everything was not what it seems
for sale as she rebranded herself from
child star to legit actor
i i feel like this time i'm just so
confident and comfortable and i feel
free more than i've ever felt in my
whole life she opens up about her
journey to that place on the hollywood
reporters awards chatter podcast i'm not
going to be one to just be like poor me
or woe is me because
i have slowly pushed through that and
i'm really glad but it was very
frustrating there were moments where i
felt like i was
i was just like i don't i don't have
what it takes to do this but now selena
says she's only grown from it and is
grateful for her past i am so grateful
because
everything that i've done i've earned
and i've worked really hard for and i
would never replace that for the world
if everything was handed to me i
guarantee you i would be a totally
different person and i've seen that
happen in people and that's so
disheartening it's something she opened
up to et about in 2012 too around the
time wizards of waverly place rap it's
been interesting watching that
transition go throughout the years i
mean there were girls that are my that
were my age 16 when i started and now
they're 1920 with me and we kind of grew
up together so in a way some of my fans
have already grown with me and others
i'm gaining new fans that are still
young do you have any regrets yet i mean
are you do you think you're too
i don't like regrets okay i mean i've
made mistakes but i mean everything
happens for a reason another thing she
doesn't regret her past relationships
[Music]
selena shared hints about her love life
and her music which came up during the
thr chat the star says her breakup with
justin bieber and the public attention
surrounding it only made her stronger i
do know that during that time i was
learning so much about myself i was you
know obviously going through a really
tough breakup it was really hard but you
know being on the other side of it i
have to be honest it's it's actually
it's actually been
really good for me um
it allowed me to develop such a
character
where i don't tolerate any sort of
nonsense in any way
and i think i'm really proud of how i've
come out of it and selena has a lot to
be proud of right now i'm just i'm in a
really happy place it's been good in the
last year alone she nabbed her first
grammy nomination for her ep revelation
um i cried of like a little baby i was
very excited
and i worked really hard on that project
so it was
a lovely surprise turn the pandemic into
a positive filming three seasons of her
hit cooking show selena and chef it's
gonna remove this inside
like a professional
like a professional look at that
ann earned rave reviews for her biggest
adult acting project yet on hulu's only
murders in the building our lives blow
up but we all go down for this
don't you want to clear your name too
i have to see this thorough season two
is on its way and judging by what selena
and her co-stars steve martin and martin
short told e.t last month we all better
buckle up more crime more murder
yeah that's in crime and murder yeah and
murder
mixed with kind of an element of crime
yeah yes and death
permeates really funny yeah
we can't tell you anything no it's
honestly gonna be great we want it to be
the best one
[Music]
you